hello and welcome to 0 plane yo chic
yeah he's a dangerous tactical player
playing usually somewhat shady openings
but we'll see what happens I've had lots
of good positions that are lost at the
end that's a typical the also
technically focus player skill for
divorce somehow what I had never seen
this move interesting so okay
20 go takes root X 97 e6 somehow but i
can i can take me three down
okay so i can play okay if I take here
you will take the seven you will take
the seven okay I should have thought
about this for a moment ok sugar three
rupees sound and I'm it is double
attacking okay so it's all about active
pieces here interesting 95 this is
smooth
and I was relying on Bishop f 3 i'm not
able now to play it 95 okay I mean maybe
I can do this and then just drop back to
draw back to fade
ok so I cannot take it and now he wants
to go 90 for what ok he's always play
for those tricks and stuff now you find
an F for you
nated it works i mean it is i decided
this a way to play he's got Knight to c6
year coming
okay pawn takes rook a three years
trapped he tricked me again in this game
jana before i was thinking no more of
course not rubbing it in yeah it's well
played what can you do yeah it's pretty
much winning here
could have had this much easier but it's
still very good and for the time yep
check time warning
yeah it should have been over a long
time ago check
it's still losing though
check check check check check check hey
it's losing check yeah yeah he outplayed
me there very nicely technically i mean
i thinkI five is just no it's just bad
of course but you have to you have to be
super precise and that I am NOT I'm just
not it exposes the center and cannot be
good quite clearly ok so the capture is
already the issue 97 is good for black
and yeah this is a week porn is quite
clearly so the engine gives this and
yeah I mean this is just a week porn
likes better him what can you do and
here the issue is sat night see 3 yeah
it's interesting it's really interesting
of course I was thinking that I'm
threatening to take on a 3 take all the
five but I'm not and here this is the
position where probably you have to be
very precise to be still be okay because
of those ideas 95 and so on after that
I'm probably in trouble it's 394 s is
very very strong very very strong player
I cannot take because f4
and he spotted this they said he's
technically very strong if he does not
play 94 now I'm totally fine yeah but he
found this very strong move a message
and yeah okay well here is a lot better
and I thought he can just take a maid
and Edwin and this is this is a lot
easier here's some of the game continued
its still winning for him but I was
checked somehow a surprise that
challenges continues and continues and
continued but ok I'm losing mmm so yeah
the opening is very questionable but
black has to be precise so it's like a
good for one game this kind of thing one
blitz game 97 and a lot stronger yeah
the computer gives us the best line 93
takes takes takes takes and black wins
upon its not winning yet but it's a big
Center pon ya next time ok well thanks
for watching